In 2019,
I was working from my laptop,
from a beautiful beach in Bali.
Drinking water right out
of a fresh coconut
and enjoying the warm ocean breeze,
and I'm thinking, meh.
Something was still missing,
and I couldn’t put my finger on it.
How could I be in this scenario
and not feel fulfilled?
I worked from 12 countries
in 12 months that year.
An opportunity that was once rare
is now more possible
for more people than ever before.
Spotify recently introduced their new
"work from anywhere" policy
in which they're giving employees
a choice of working
wherever they do their most focused
and creative thinking.
Dropbox's new way of working
is called "Virtual first,"
in which remote work will be
the primary experience for employees,
saving in-person meetings
for special occasions.
And that's great news
because over 50 percent of people
that work remotely say
that if their current company
doesn't give them
some type of remote work option long-term,
they'll look for a job
at a company that does.
Well, problem solved, right?
Except what people are saying
and what they're doing is inconsistent.
In fact, according
to a recent McKinsey study,
workplace flexibility wasn't even one
of the top five reasons
people quit their jobs in the past year.
More freedom at work
doesn't mean more fulfillment.
Let me take you back to the end of 2018.
I'm two years into doing my job
as the director of talent development
for a New York-based tech company.
And I'm doing what I love to do the most,
creating and launching employee
development programs from scratch.
And then my boss says to me,
"Next year is going to be
the year of maintenance,
focusing on refining existing programs
instead of launching new ones."
I'm not a maintenance-mode person.
While I understand its importance,
it's really not where I shine,
so I wasn't looking forward
to the year ahead.
Meanwhile, I was reading new research
on the future of work,
and all signs were pointing
to a remote and hybrid-work future.
We now know that the pandemic
accelerated that by at least a decade.
I even found a work-and-travel program
that coordinates a group of professionals
to work remotely from around the world
with coworking spaces and living
accommodations in each city.
I was immediately hooked.
I had always wanted to travel
for a longer period of time,
but I thought I'd have to quit my job
in order to do that.
Then I thought, well, I could do
maintenance mode from anywhere.
And given my current company's
global expansion plans,
I knew I had to think about where current
and future employees could be located.
If I could convince my company
that I should work remotely
to better understand the opportunities
and challenges that remote workers face,
it could be a win-win for both of us.
And a month later,
I ended my apartment lease,
sold my furniture
and hopped on a one-way flight
from cold and snowy New York City
to Lima, Peru,
to start my year-long trip with my cohort.
And let me tell you,
those first few months were incredible.
I attended a virtual team meeting
for my coworking space at Lima
before heading out to go surfing
at sunset on a regular Tuesday.
I launched a work program
from inside of a pool
in Puerto Escondido, Mexico.
And I negotiated a contract
from a cafe in Hanoi, Vietnam,
before jumping on the back of a motorbike
to go eat bun cha with friends.
I met remote workers and digital
nomads from around the world.
Each of us had a different story
of how we got there.
Some had just been divorced
or gotten out of long-term relationships
and convinced their employers
to let them work remotely
so that they could get away.
There were three corporate lawyers
who all hated their jobs
and thought that doing them from a beach
would make it more tolerable.
And some just wanted to be as far away
from micromanagement and office politics
as possible.
But still, after a few months,
when that honeymoon period was over
and the novelty faded,
we realized that traveling was just
a Band-Aid solution for the real problems.
I wondered, how could we get
this "work from anywhere" life right?
So I interviewed dozens of remote workers,
I conducted a focus group,
and I surveyed hundreds of people.
And you know what I saw in all that data?
Wherever you go, there you are.
If you hate your job in Houston,
you will hate it in Hanoi.
What really needs fixing
is your motivation to do the work itself.
We believe we need
a certain amount of money
to create or maintain
the lifestyle that we've envisioned.
We think we need a specific job title
that aligns with the identity
that we or our parents imagined
for us a decade ago.
And we don't realize that we get stuck
in the motions of work routines
without intention.
Minimizing these pressures
around your money,
identity and routines
and focusing on opportunities
for more growth, impact and joy
is the key to a more fulfilling career
no matter where you're located.
And the good news is that you might
not have to overhaul your career
or life to feel fulfilled.
Esther Perel, world-renowned
psychotherapist and couples counselor,
says that in the West today,
most of us are going to have two or three
marriages or committed relationships,
and some of us are going to do it
with the same person.
Think about that for a second.
She's saying that some of us will build
and experience a new relationship
with the same person.
Perhaps something similar could be said
about your relationship to your work
at the same company.
Perhaps after a challenging time,
an enticing external offer
or having been together for a while,
instead of breaking up,
you could find and create
a better path forward together.
And I'm not saying you're going to get
everything you want
out of your current job,
but given how much time
you spend working,
isn't it worth a shot to make it
as fulfilling as possible?
When the pandemic hit
and much of the world went remote,
I saw my corporate friends in the States
follow the exact same trajectory
that we did abroad.
The thrill of working home
in your pajamas,
having more flexibility
with your schedule,
being able to do the laundry
in between meetings,
all of which can make a real difference
in improving your daily life.
But still, once the novelty faded
and the reality set in,
people had to face whatever
underlying issues they'd had
before the pandemic started.
When the perks of an office job
were taken away,
whether it was the free snacks
in the break room,
the water-cooler conversation
with colleagues,
what people were left with
was the work itself
and their motivation,
or lack thereof, to do it.
And they began to ask themselves
really important questions:
Do I even like my job?
Is this really worth my time?
Is this what I want to be doing?
And these are great questions to ask.
The problem is, for way too many people,
they thought they had to completely
overhaul their career or life.
More people voluntarily
quit their jobs in 2021
than any other year in recorded history.
They wanted a fresh start and a new
beginning after a challenging time.
Here's the kicker, though.
Almost 50 percent of the people
that did find jobs after quitting
say that their new job has not lived up
to their expectations.
They found out, just like we did
in Peru, Mexico and Vietnam,
that wherever you go, there you are.
Perhaps you could start
the next chapter of your career
in an organization that knows you,
where you've built credibility
and trust and a network,
and where they'd be willing to let you
try things you haven't done before.
Now, I'm not saying you should stay
in a toxic work environment.
And sometimes you do need
a larger-scale change,
like a new job or a new career.
But before you make a decision
that you think will make you happier,
I want you to consider that happiness
is a feeling that doesn't last.
It often is what we want in the moment
and depends on external circumstances.
What does last, however, is fulfillment.
Fulfillment is richer,
deeper and longer-term
and often takes a longer amount of time
and intention to get it.
As you look to generate fulfillment,
I want you to consider three questions
tied to three of its key components
that are more internally driven.
The first is joy.
What kind of work energizes you
that you'd love to do more of?
Now, I want you to remember that just
because you're good at something,
it doesn't mean that you enjoy doing it.
So really consider what gives you
a deep feeling of contentment.
Next is impact.
How could you provide more value
to your company or clients
by doing this kind of work?
And if you're having trouble answering
that question, then ask your manager,
your peers or clients directly.
Focus on work that's in that sweet spot
of meeting both your interests
and the client's needs
or the business needs.
And finally, growth.
Which knowledge or skills could you
develop through these experiences?
Feeling a sense of progress
toward meaningful work
is one of the biggest
drivers of fulfillment.
I asked myself these same three questions
when I was feeling happy
yet not fulfilled with my life
working from a beach.
And I found out that I find
joy in interviewing,
researching and talking to remote
workers about their lives.
I made a significant impact
by facilitating workshops
to help them develop
their skills and their careers.
And growth came in the form
of me figuring out
how to distill a career's worth
of the best HR advice and expertise
into an easily digestible book
for remote workers.
Thousands of organizations
around the world
are finally understanding the importance
of giving employees a choice
of where to work.
And while being given that choice
is certainly meaningful,
what’s even more empowering
is the fulfillment that comes
from doing work
that truly lights you up,
wherever you are.
Thank you.